if you celebrate Easter you'll probably
be dying some eggs here's what science
has to say about making them look
brilliant to start most food dyes only
work in acid like vinegar which is five
percent acetic acid we wanted to know
exactly what pH gets you the best
saturation so we tested six different
conditions along the pH scale from pure
water at pH 7 to pure vinegar at pH 3
the color saturation depends on the bond
between the shell surface and the dyes
molecules pure water barely activates
the acid dye pure vinegar makes for more
vibrant colors but there's a hitch see
that bubbling that's free protons from
the acid reacting with the shells
calcium carbonate creating co2 bubbles
that can leave you with a blotchy egg we
found that for bright well bonded colors
the ideal pH is 4 of course you could
use other edible acids like lemon juice
but there's something about the width of
vinegar that just says spring